i'm saying like like the reason that
people are against planned parenthood is
because they provide three hundred
thousand abortions per year that's why
they're protesting we all go that's one
of the that's one of those three hundred
thousand like people think you can't
make three thousand like that many
mistakes in your life i mean it's just
no but it's not just one person it's the
whole like country of
yeah but that's thought
but they also it's funny though like
they've been crap like states like texas
have been cracking down on planned
parenthood and shutting down a lot of
planned parenthoods and that's been
happening for quite a few years so this
is not something new that's come out of
nowhere like these rights it's always
been kind of like
yeah and like texas like a lot of the
kind of
states yeah they're conservative states
but i find it ironic that a provider of
birth control which lowers
pregnancy rates especially like
unplanned and unwanted pregnancies
they're cracking down on the thing which
also helps to secure that so it's like
yes they provide abortions but they also
provide protection like condoms and they
also provide other birth control like
the pill
um
yeah like injections and stuff too so
it's like well they're gonna have more
unplanned pregnancies and more people
wanting abortions if they don't have
safe access to birth control well and
that's a health care issue well i don't
think most people are against like
contraceptions but i think the issue is
the people that are against
contraception they're saying like i you
shouldn't be able to take my tax dollars
to fund something i don't believe in
because there are certain like religions
that don't believe in birth
in in the us right like
obviously in the uk in the uk if you're
looking from that like oh we have access
to like free to pharmacy like we have
the free free plan people we have the
free like condoms up to i think 25 i
believe correctly you have like a condom
called you go in and purchase whatever
in us you don't get that type of access
you have to pay for everything like
obviously that's not to say that like
people don't take um precautions doing
that but you have to pay for your condos
which are for when i went there was
pretty they're not cheap neither is the
plan p bill uh and some of the other
contributions because you have to pay
for everything in the us so i feel like
that's why it could be
more like unplugged prices because most
people will be like they don't want to
pay for that so they're just taking
risks type thing think it's very classic
like a classic like a class motivated
like thing that people in like
conservative states don't want poor
people to have access to those
health care
no i don't again it's a religious thing
so the people the people that the people
that are very against provide like one
i'm telling you conservatives it's not
the birth control that they want that
they're most conservatives are fine with
free birth control the ones that aren't
it's a religious thing but
it's but but the the reason that planned
parenthood are conservatives aren't for
planned parenthood is because they they
literally give you 300 000 abortions per
year like that that's a [ __ ] ton of
abortion
right but i think that a lot of people
that can be put into the society and
then end up in a situation where they
could either be unwanted or degenerated
because of their skin tone or
any of the any of the above so you're
saying okay it's 300 000 people or
babies who are not who are aborted and
who aren't coming into the world yet
that's probably
i think it's around 50 percent that
actually make it out of being a newborn
baby
i think i'm not 50 percent
like when you give birth actually
survive after by themselves in life
i'm not 100 sure but i think i heard
something along those lines even though
i think that's true
of births like 50 percent
so if you have 300 000 people a year in
the world
it would just bring multiple problems
additional problems to society like what
like what i said for example bringing in
for example what if all these people who
wanted abortions
don't want the child anymore that's
ended up being an adoption into care
homes what's wrong with adoption
nothing's wrong with kids
a lot of government funding but there's
not a lot of government funding within
those sectors so then they are treated
less of a human being
in regards to do you think their life is
less valuable because they're poor hell
nice or they're adopted hello because
that's that's what you're insinuating
i'm saying that's how they're treated by
society and they're not like they're not
being loved so yes they're
yes adoption is good but the
practicality of it is that a lot of
people are not being adopted and a lot
of people cannot be adopted or even when
like i'm in foster care say i'm a foster
care and let's pretend just for the sake
of document i'm 15.
my parents died and i'm in the system i
have a four-year-old sister and a
six-year-old brother
and this is where my parents left well
no one wants to adopt us um
or like even consider fostering us
because it's like
no maybe it could be a racial thing how
she was suggesting like people may not
like them because of race or simply
because like we're a set of siblings
like oh i can't split them up but these
a lot of government in america like
anything that is government-funded
is totally underfunded and it's not
going to be allocated the resources that
it would need to to make it evident that
these um foster kids or adopted there's
that's not true though there's a lot of
like catholic and like christian
organizations that specifically help
with adoption right no i'm not enough to
even
touch the surface yeah put it to put you
this way yeah like number number wise in
the world right there's over seven
billion people in the world right if you
look at it like this right if everyone
was so
wanting to adopt yeah they would not
again so my parents adopted like i know
a decent amount about adoption my
parents gave up a kid for adoption and
my parents they adopted three like three
of my siblings were adopted and the
issue the issue is that it's legally
it's very hard because you can't you
have to make sure that the the parents
are safe well only conservative people
can really adopt i feel in america that
you've got to be like married and be in
a secure relationship not necessarily
not necessarily it is shifting but it's
more so that you need a lot of money
which is what you're doing it's very
difficult to adopt
as well so i feel like it's unrealistic
to say that that will compensate for
those people that we've given away their
children
50 of um women over 30 are single and
childless like there's a fur there's
going to be a fertility they don't they
don't want that some of them don't
that goes to why they're trying to like
no i'm saying marriage is getting later
and later so there's going to be
fertility issues coming in like of
course yeah but they do
it the statistics show that people who
marry later in life they have a lower
divorce rate
it's the cases the highest divorce rates
are people who married in younger ages
between 15 and 24 and then also in the
ages between like 24 and and 30. i i
heard the highest marriage
when i looked at it it was between 25
and 30 was
the highest marriage rate so where did
you get that from the height what the
highest divorce rate yeah yeah
okay it was like statistics i was
looking through actually after we had
our chat like i was going on like
different you might you might be i think
it's like kind of like going hand in
hand yeah yeah yeah because you're doing
divorce right you're doing marriage yeah
yeah sorry i'm not talking about
marriage rates i'm talking about the
heart
you're right you're right yeah yeah yeah
like people who get married
younger
yeah they have they have higher divorce
rates so i think um it's maybe not a bad
thing like if you're looking at people
who are waiting to get married but
they're actually staying married like
divorce is not nice
especially if you've got kids in the mix
there like it's not a nice thing my dad
is a product of a broken home
like and he always said to us and like
luckily both my parents are still
married they've been married over 30
years like but
for a lot of people that's not the case
and it's it's never ideal and it's not a
nice situation to have to bring kids
into so um i feel like it's a good you
know if the if the sacrifice is okay
people are getting married later in life
well most women can still have kids
going into their 30s so say if you get
married within your 30s like okay great
you can still have kids and you actually
stay ninety percent of your eggs are
gone by thirty
thirty five after thirty five they also
provide their facilities to freeze eggs
right and those people who have the
money to facilitate that option will be
the people who are considered to adopt
the wait say that again so the people
who have the money to actually access
the um option of freezing their eggs
obviously because that is very expensive
some expensive procedures yeah a lot of
me not a lot of people do have that type
of option yeah
how much does it cost to give birth in
the united states
i found out that that wasn't free like
yesterday i was like yeah
but you don't know that you don't think
i just think
if you made a choice to have sex you you
should deal with the kind imagine you're
16 you don't even have like but i think
i i do agree with that but i think
that's the separation
at a time one at a time go ahead i think
that's a separate issue in america
because just i honestly i think
everything in america is [ __ ] up but
right
no that's true because obviously
in america like you pay for like
everything the only thing that's right
when you go to a shop to buy a simple
drink right
you get taxed on that and then that tax
is supposed to go to your like healthy
and whatever but you go in to do
anything you can dance whatever i'm
saying just in general like um like if
you want to go um
sorry like get a dental whatever you pay
like your insurance but like you still
pay for that treatment and it's a lot of
money so giving childbirth i would
see would be a lot of money i don't
disagree that it's expensive sure but
like again you made that choice like i'm
25
i've never gotten pregnant okay then do
we punish the women who aren't
financially stable enough to actually
like what if you can't pay to have about
like yeah
you want to have a kid you want to have
a kid
you realize what that's doing that's
like
saying that like poor people's lives are
less valuable than richmond
let me finish because they're the ones
you would be aborting because those are
the ones who would be aborting more in
this scenario so it's like you're
insinuating that they're less valuable
and they deserve life less no i'm like
simulating their experience is
completely different to more wealthy
people which are more likely to be
conservative right because like someone
that comes from a poor background has to
make a choice
am i going to be like completely
financially unstable but making a choice
to give birth when i don't have the
money to pay for the birth itself right
like i go like that's already like i'm
going to start right in a terrible
position so why would you put yourself
in that situation but they're not
putting themselves in that situation no
but yeah she's going to say that because
that if you know that you don't have the
means then you shouldn't be having sex
it's it's not viable to say that anyway
because at the end of the day if we are
talking about biology it's natural
innate to
have sex right right but then also to
the people who are we are talking of the
lower class and don't have the access to
go get an abortion these are also the
same people or health care yeah that
don't have
the
the um what's the what i'm saying
resources to prevent that from happening
like contraceptive pills like condoms or
abstinence
but in abstinence isn't it an effective
um they've already shown but this is the
other thing that education the sexual
health education in england is terrible
but the sexual health education in
america is way worse and it varies state
to stay overall overall education is
better what education do you need you
know if you have sex you are going to
get pre like you have the option to get
pregnant you know there's con like i'm
sorry i don't know my soup
my people
okay i went to catholic school we had no
sex ed
but it's it's just common sense well
you're a smart girl so it might seem
like common sense but i'll tell you
there's some people that really don't
really don't know stupid i'm really
clueless and if no one tells them
they'll they'll go okay you're telling
me there's 15 year olds that have no
idea you can get pregnant
i'm not gonna say get pregnant internet
today come on no no no get pregnant but
like they will think like oh like
i only need to do this on this day like
some people are like oh you can't get
pregnant on your period like small like
misconceptions can get you pregnant like
if i have sex and water like some people
think certain things
that logically if you're educated you
wouldn't get to that point but these are
misconceptions that a young person can
make easily without the right education
so
but